Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur "Detective"
Un jeu...
Popopo t'as pas l'impression que  l'inspecteur Squeezie est l'homme de la situation là ?
Ouais, ouais, je... hum... ok, j'vais me jeter par la fenêtre, j'ai compris.
C'est parti pour une nouvelle enquête d'inspecteur Squeezie
Ok, c'est parti, on est actuellement le détective et en gros on doit trouver si la personne avec qui on parle est un robot ou si c'est une vraie personne.
Hello! Déjà on dit "bonjour"
Parce qu'on est poli.
Hello, ok...
Peux-tu penser ? ça, ça va nous mettre sur la piste
Bip, détective.
Bip... Bip bip de...non, bip, heu... robot...  Ca fait Bip bip
Tu aimes la chantilly ? Si c'est un robot techniquement il a jamais mangé de chantilly, il saura pas nous répondre.
Il va bloquer
Bip Bip
Est ce que tu peux dire autre chose que bip , bip bip détective ?
C'est une blague ?
C'est une comédie ?? hinhinhaa
Hooo ok
Non mais c'est forcément un robot
C'est sur et certains
Qui est ton youtubeur favoris ?
Ivy
Quoi? C'est qui Ivy ?
C'est elle ? C'est qui Ivy?
Si ça s'trouve il est fan de DC Comics et il parlent de Poison Ivy
Cette femme la .... bon elle elle est pas comme sa dans DC Comics haha
Bip Bip
Ok on passe aux choses sérieuses, on va relever l' ADN.
Il n'y a plus qu'a mettre dans la machine qui scanne,  et hop!
ADN égal Squeezie!
Putain putain , je le savais !
ça nous avance pas ...
C’est un jeu soigné, hein
Tu fermes ta gueule , tu fermes ta gueule !
Putin les relevés d' ADN n'ont pas marché, comment on va faire ?
Heeuuu bip bip détective, j'en ai marre, j'en ai marre la...
L'inspecteur squeezie va ... son crane va exploser.
Ok ok  j'ai une question ...
Qui est ton perso préféré dans Futurama ?
Vous voyez ou je veux en venir?
Je ne sais pas ! Tu es sur? Il est métallique....
Aller.... laisse toi faire, laisse toi aller dans le piège ....
Peut-étre, mais je pense que je ne suis pas sur parce que je sait ce que je suis, bip bip détective.
Tu contournes la question gamin...
ça c'est les profs sévères qui réfléchissent comme ça.
Théo 8 sur 20
Qu'est ce que tu bois ?
Dit moi t'es plutôt boissons sucrées ou plutôt essence  pour faire marcher ton moteur de robot ?
Ivy.
Ivyk ..
Mister V , mister v le ride
tu bois du ride
Huumm ouais
Ok on récap , quel est ton film préféré?
ça serait pas par hasard, Iron Man, Robocop, Transformers..?
Prout
Heeuuuu
Aime tu la mécanique?
Hum jackson
Tu es occupé ?
Répond à la question ...
BIP
Attend ça ce trouve en faite il veux qu'on le bip, ça ce trouve il veut juste qu'on le bip.
Mais oui on va le biper ....
Voila..
on la bipé, alors...
Tin , Ok ont sort les lunettes qu'on ne sort que dans des enquêtes, très, très difficile .
J'en appel aux lunettes badass
Alors ... es tu un robot ou un humain ?
On va droit aux but , j'en ai marre de toutes ces conneries.
Je suis moi et un humain...
Attendez ...
Attendez je crois que j'ai trouver .. SONY
SONY la lettre O
la lettre O ressemble au bouton rouge de ce synthé
Ce synthé si on fait, haut,  haut, bas, bas, gauche, droite...
Il s'envole , envole, e, n, v, o, l, e.
Envole,  mot en six lettres
N, a, r, u, t, o , six lettres
Six lettres donne 41 , 4 +1 cinq
Cinq c'est le nombres de lettres qui vient de robot .... Faux
c'est le moment de vérité, tu es un robot ! ...
Correct
C'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo , un peut facile on va pas ce mentir .
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plus <3
Si vous voulez faire appel a mes services mes honoraires sont dans la descriptions, c'est extrêmement cher ...
Voila c'est déjà la fin , on ce retrouve demain, parce que je suis hyper content
C'est une enquéte de plus résolue par l'inspecteur Squeezie
Et on peut tomber sur un joueur,  c'est ça le délire c'est que c'est sois un robot ou sois un joueur pour de vraie
C'est pas à chaque fois un robot !
Non mais je vous vois dans l'ombre à essayer de critiquer le skill d'inspecteur Squezzie là
Vous êtes encore en C.A.P inspection quand moi j'ai mon masteur enquêteur.
Allez, à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous à plus, portez-vous bien,  tchao tout le monde, PEACE!
<3